Roy Anika is a royal correspondent for
The Sunday Times she's with us from
London with the latest on this story
Roy a good morning I know everybody
wants to go and we keep hearing that
Harry and Megan want this to be a shared
event so I'm curious about what that
means and how it will be different from
the other royal weddings that we've
watched well I think I think two things
straightaway first of all they are
having more than 1/2 thousand people
inside the grounds of Windsor Castle
members of the public members of
charities they work with some schools
from Windsor so they can feel they can
take part of it and then straight after
their marriage we're going to see all
their guests from sin George's Chapel go
go on to the reception but Megan and how
are you going to get into a carriage and
do really quite long carriage procession
around the streets of Windsor and that
will be another opportunity for them to
share the wedding with members the
public so they can see them and feel
they can celebrate in their day and I
think those kind of things a Harry and
Megan's touches to want to sort of make
this a very public people's wedding so
we know that it doesn't look like Elton
John made the cut but do we know who did
we do we do know a few people who did I
was actually out in Malawi last year
with people that Harry had worked with
on a conservation project he's invited
them they're traveling all the way over
for the wedding
he's also invited Prince say-so of
lassoo to who he co-founded his charity
centre barley with he's coming naturally
Figueres a very famous Argentinean polo
player is coming and also in a sort of
quite poignant move Megan and Harry have
invited survivors of the grenfell fire
tragedy was big fire that happened here
lost Doon community members and
survivors of that will be inside st.
George's Chapel have you heard about any
Americans who are coming I think it's
better I think it's better Gail there'll
be a healthy dose from the cast of suits
among the congregation I think we'll
expect to see some of Megan's close
friends and customers from suits also
you know a few of her friends from
California we know will be there and
then of course there are people like
Jessica Mulroney who's her stylist based
in Toronto he'll be over so I think
it'll be a very international guest list
and is there talk about honoring
Princess Diana in
way.i there isn't really talk about it
because I think it's pretty much assumed
that it will happen in the same way as
at William and Kate's wedding
there were tribute sadhana particularly
in the evening reception and speeches
I'm almost certain that either in the
order of service at some daughter's
Chapel and probably in the receptions -
there will be tribute paid I'm sure
Harry will mention his mother I'm sure
we'll see something of her in the order
of service - that there's no doubt
Harry's very keen to keep Diana's memory
involved in his wedding and not to
belabor this royal but do you really
believe Elton John was not invited
Gail's upset well who knows maybe maybe
not you know the Spice Girls said they
were invited it turns out they're not
Elton John he's done a lot of work with
Harry on HIV and AIDS when he sang song
okay maybe she'll affirm evening
maybe he's performing exactly that
exactly Nica thanks so much for being
with us this morning